the
playoff baseball survival and prison
escapes yeah games with gold has some
traditional October activities and some
epic surprises games with gold has four
new titles that are all playable and
acquirable on xbox one and free to those
with an active xbox live gold
subscription starting in October first
step up to the plate with super mega
baseball extra innings customize your
players in this detailed baseball
simulation which adjusts the difficulty
to ensure beginners and seasoned gamers
can play together seamlessly next up on
October sixteenth plan your own prison
break with the escapists with a little
bit of stealth a little bit of strategy
and a whole lot of surprises you'll get
a glimpse into prison light and a thirst
for freedom on the xbox 360 and Xbox one
via backward compatibility break free
from the road and carve your own path
and MX vs atv reflex the track will
transform underneath you on every lap
giving you more opportunities to gain an
advantage or wreck disastrously then on
October sixteenth explore a desolate
post-apocalyptic city in imli as a lone
survivor trying to find their family now
is the time to deal with the dangers and
difficulties of surviving in an
uncertain future to redeem the titles
simply click on the gold area on your
xbox one on your xbox 360 or even on the
web at xbox calm forward slash games
with gold your new games will
automatically appear in the ready to
install section of your Xbox one with
Xbox Live Gold you are part of the
world's premier gaming community